wedding season drawing to a close with
the economy here's the problem still
recovering a lot of couples on a very
tight budget so if you're planning to
still have a wedding sometime in late
August early September
here are some money-saving wedding
planning tips from our prop master built
all these will save you a lot of money
take a head of broccoli spray paint it
white boom
bouquet here's bill with another tip cut
a piece out of your screen door boom
wedding veil and another one
[Applause]
[Music]
grab a hipster rip the spacers out of
his ears boom wedding rings here's
another one find a homeless guy give
them a touch to the microphone boom best
man here's another one
[Music]
punch out the bartender boom open bar
[Applause]
[Music]
show the bride a video of Jake
Gyllenhaal working out boom here comes
the bride
[Music]
[Applause]
take a stack of cans cover it in shaving
cream
it was supposed to be a wedding
[Applause]
I thought it actually looked pretty good
white yeah wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]